[Music]
what he misses most are the simple
things like going on a walk with his dad
twelve-year-old dana's lost both of his
parents to cobit 19.
his uncle joins him to pay tribute at
the family grave
danas is one of around 15 000 children
in indonesia orphaned by the pandemic
so far more than 140 000 indonesians
have died since the start of the
pandemic
two-thirds of them between june and
october 2021 alone
and the second deadly wave is still
raging claiming more and more lives
leaving loved ones behind to mourn
welcome to our kobe 19 special i'm
monica jones good to have you with us
in early summer indonesia became the
global epicenter of the coronavirus
pandemic on the island of java
volunteers help bury the dead
antonio zayano puts his life on the line
caring for the dead the 53 year old is a
member of a so-called quick burial team
one of the many covet 19 volunteer
groups in the city of jakarta their
motto is
people of joho district we are
responsive agile and tough
the volunteers help overwhelm cemetery
officials to deal with the many covet 19
victims in indonesia despite much lower
case numbers in recent weeks their help
in this part of java is still needed
i am suffering from all the heat
and all the sweat
sometimes the funerals process is
entirely in our hands because the others
are afraid
it's not just that some people are
afraid many gravediggers are simply
exhausted and can no longer for instance
collect bodies from people's homes
during the peak of the pandemic
graveyards were open around the clock
in july alone
570 people died here more than in the
previous 12th month
normally hayono works as a cleaner but
in the pandemic people like him have
prevented the entire system from
collapsing his family is proud that he
volunteers
but they also fear he might get infected
if he gets infected
he will have to quarantine
and that leaves me a self-employed
housewife all by myself
and it's only me looking after our
children
the volunteers hope that the fast burial
of bodies will not only bring down the
infection risk enhance the mortality
rate but also help to reduce the
psychological burden for morning
families
hayono is a christian and says he
regards helping as a duty
is it a risk yes
we're actually a little afraid but we
throw that fear away and put our hope in
the almighty
it's great to help people in need
and make sure things run smoothly and
safely and with all the precautions in
place haryana is positive that he can
achieve this goal at the end of the day
with a negative result
for more i'm joined now by making gibral
from the east java kobe 19 task force in
surabaya and ahmad utomo a molecular
biological or biological consultant and
lecturer at the university yarsi in
jakarta good to have you both with us i
would like to start with you makian
because as a member of the kovid 19 task
force what do you do to keep the virus
under control
yeah well basically we are surprised
because in the june and the july the
cases of kobe 19 in indonesia are
spiking
very high suddenly so in only around
three weeks or hospitals occupancy rate
from around 20 percent uh occupied to
about 80 percent
so basically we are surprised first
however we do realize that to make sure
that the split of coffee 19 can be
controlled we need to believe and apply
science and also the recommendation from
who we need to make sure that we have of
enough capacity of testing so we can
achieve the positive rate of below five
percent we also need to make sure that
the tracing ratio also more than 30 per
each cases that we want and of course we
need to make sure that we have
sufficient hospital capacity and of
course of course we need to collaborate
because yeah we we have a very complex
government and also
we have a lot of things to collaborate
if we are working around
working alone without collaborating with
the people in collaborating with the
military of the police we might not be
able to achieve that right it's
interesting that you say you are
surprised by that surge ahmad perhaps
you can shed light on it what triggered
the surge in june i think it started
well it could be
two factors though the virus factor and
also the human factor you know the virus
like a sport car it's a next generation
sport car but as good as a sport car it
cannot run in a in a very bad road right
so uh we know before they actually the
search the
the social movement is not that
restricted and then the
the people contact is very close uh it's
very difficult to control so i guess the
virus can spread quite easily especially
when the one has easier
a way of transmission now the question
is in indonesia what we have problem is
when it comes to the human one is the
the poor quarantine
policy and especially to the foreign
travelers and also the contact tracing
is also not that good so when like dr
mahyan mentioned that we should have at
least 30 people for every one case
that's not really being uh done so this
could be a problem we cannot really
mitigate as quickly as possible so that
is actually the the one we have to keep
in mind when come controlling this
pandemic okay
about this report
with volunteers helping undertakers bury
the debt how risky is that how risky is
it to actually get infected
right when it comes to the debt of
course the one in close contact
especially the undertakers that clearly
is actually posting a great risk so uh
certainly we appreciate what they have
done um however you have to also keep in
mind that
when this builder control has to be in a
very in isolation what we want to
prevent is the crowd because the general
rituals of the uh the bearing of the
dead involving so many people uh coming
uh to the houses and also to the
cemetery so at least that part is
mitigated but certainly for those people
those uh care under uh takers that
clearly is putting some risk to their
family as well but i noticed that they
have been wearing a good uh protective
clothing so that should actually
minimize the risk all right that's good
to know uh makian uh on the upside i
mean statistics suggests that the
infection rate across indonesia could
actually have peaked so things could get
better how hopeful are you because
you're working on the ground uh that
this wave could soon be under control
yeah basically we can see that at june
and july the
daily cases of copy 19 indonesia are
very high even there you will reach more
than 40 000 cases per day and more than
thousands of deaths per day but now we
can see that the trends are declining
around 80 until 90 percent so we believe
that there is a positive sign that
probably the control depending indonesia
uh
in the right way to be controlled and
also we can see that the vaccination
rate was quite satisfying because we
have 105 million of indonesian citizens
who are vaccinated the first dose or
similar with 50
and 29.4
of indonesian are already vaccinated so
hopefully uh
the collaborative combination between
the good testing and tracing and also
treatment with the vaccination and also
the uh social restrictive movement
because we already uh pulled the
emergency bridges which uh led by our
minister of uh so so thank you
things are looking up i take it uh and
that's also good to know machine gibral
from the east java kovid 19 task force
and ahmad utomo from the university crc
in jakarta thank you so much
thank you very much
thank you
time for one of your questions now over
to derek
will covet 19 become endemic with
seasonal surges
let's start by clarifying the difference
between pandemic covet 19 which is what
we're facing now
and endemic covet 19 which is what most
public health experts now believe will
face in the future
a pandemic
is when an infectious disease moves
beyond local and and regional boundaries
and affects people
on a wide scale
usually worldwide with
unpredictable fluctuations
the term endemic disease describes a
background disease that's that's
relatively constant in a population over
time or at least
constant enough that we can predict
patterns of transmission
with some accuracy
the bugs that cause colds or seasonal
flu are endemic for instance they're
always there
but we know for example that they'll
generally affect more people in the
wintertime and we can forecast broadly
how many
and that knowledge
helps make them manageable
but it's still impossible at this point
to guess exactly how long it'll take for
covet 19 to reach
that status many experts say because
that depends on a host of factors first
and foremost
how widespread immunity becomes
worldwide
that will depend heavily on on vaccine
take up everywhere
as well as the still open question of
how long lived protection from vaccines
proves to be
because vaccine distribution and take up
is still so different from country to
country
researchers say covid19 numbers
won't stabilize at the same time
everywhere but once it's infected most
of those who are unprotected and
survivors have at least some level of
immune protection
the general expectation is that like
other infectious respiratory diseases
covet 19
will begin to affect more predictable
numbers of people every year um we'll
learn to live with it and the pandemic
will end
saris kobe 2 will be endemic and because
we know transmission is most likely
indoors
that'll probably lead to to seasonal
surges as well
you